it has long been a Bastion for Democrats
they've dominated the state of New York
for more than two decades but Upstate
out in the suburbs this time round
changes in the air well look at the
crime rate look at the inflation look at
the price of fuel I'm inside of control
so as a as a person spending money right
you got to look at it and say how do we
not try something else for two years two
years
I haven't seen the left really do
anything I haven't seen them step up
when they said they were going to step
up and haven't seen them do anything
that's actually been effective to course
to help people so now I mean I'm
stepping out there last year and this
year just to kind of actually just put
my foot down and just be like if change
is going to happen you're gonna have to
be a part of it that's it
New York is a Bellwether State meaning
what happens here is often played out
Across America and Democrats fear a red
wave could be coming
in New York crime is the big issue above
and below ground on the subway New
Yorkers are scared
Prime in issue crime is definitely an
issue yes certainly here in New York uh
by Subway and the trains
[Music]
suburbs as well
not everyone says it'll affect their
vote I have been in New York over 40
years and this is the first time I've
been afraid to come into Manhattan but
it's not just in Manhattan I live on
Long Island you know it used to be safe
that's not safe I'm just scared and I
hate living like this and then I don't
see an end to it I think they want to
admit that the guns are the issue so
you're afraid of crime but you're not
going to vote for a party
changer or who say they're going to
bring children because they don't
believe they will
but enough voters are thinking of
supporting Republicans to have Democrats
alarmed this could be a sign of how
worried the Democrats are here in New
York they brought in some big names
to try and Shore up the votes a few days
before the midterm elections
[Applause]
[Music]
president Kamala Harris will be followed
by the president himself campaigning
here on Sunday to get out the vote
but the numbers are moving against the
Democrats oh
61. you'd expect a liberal crowd at the
drag Bingo night but even here there
were voters planning to swing the other
way
Ashley voted for Bill Clinton
so I liked Bill Clinton I thought he was
a great good for the economy and good
for the markets so and then after the
last couple of years where you see how
what's happening with everything right
now I think you got to go in a different
direction
in a key stronghold the power of
Democrats could be fading if they are
eclipsed by Republicans in New York
they're in deepening trouble across
America
Dominic wyghorns Sky News New York